so president bidens back with even more
student debt loan Shenanigans after
bribing young voters the head of the
midterm Biden once again extended the
pause on student loan payment as his 400
billion dollar handout faces serious
illegal challenges Biden used an
opportunity to blame Republican stuff
my Administration has been working to
provide student debt relief to millions
of working and middle class families
across the country Republican special
interest and elected officials sued to
deny this relief even for their own
constituents
but I'm completely confident my plan is
legal it isn't fair to ask tens of
millions of borrowers eligible for
Relief to resume their student debt
payments while the courts consider the
lawsuit
so judge before I go into the bribe
um how does this play out in court well
it's going to play out in court and he's
going to lose but the amazing thing
about it is forget the bribe I mean he
actually lied to the American people do
you recall when he said I got this
passed by Congress and it passed by one
or two votes I mean he even lied about
it it not only gave him a bump for the
midterms it's giving them a bump now so
he can like start trashing the
Republicans saying the Republicans are
are making us are putting a halt on this
thing the truth is it's costing us 195
billion dollars so far as I understand
it and the uh the average medical
student that we thought man they get ten
thousand twenty thousand at the most
they're going to get like a hundred and
seven thousand dollars credit based upon
all of these pauses and it really is
based on an emergency that does not
exist that's it
Jessica your friend and Mentor Nancy
Pelosi said that he couldn't do this
yeah I remember that doesn't have the
boy to do this so what happened what
changed
times change Lawrence okay people evolve
um there are there are a lot of people
who did say this wasn't legal there were
people who say that it was legal
Scholars obviously Elizabeth Warren has
been behind this but Biden had changed
his tune on this as well and I think he
was really following the direction of
Webb Clyburn who then it became a you
know a major piece of legislation that
he thought was important
um we'll see how it plays out but I'm
really interested to see how Republicans
who have gen Z's in their districts and
Millennials who are going to benefit
from this deal with it because you see a
lot of people on the campaign Trail and
this happens with both parties but
obviously Democrats have been in power
and you see them you know touting
infrastructure money that's coming in or
American Rescue act money and these are
things that they voted against right so
how do you look a bunch of students in
the eye or former students and say you
know well you got to tell them that
you're happy about this right because
it's going to get you the relief that
you need but you voted against it and
people hold folks accountable for things
like that and there were you know three
issues that really mattered to young
voters it was climate it was student
debt relief and it was abortion and
Republicans are going to have a very
tough time explaining away lack of
support for all three of those issues so
I think we can explain I think you can
explain this to a young person they're
not as stupid Jessica as you think they
are they understand that other people
are paying for this you know when they
did this server they found that these
people were going to spend most of their
money on like Tech Gat like gadgetry
booze and dining out so basically what
you're doing is you're taking money from
hard-working Americans to pay for the
idle luxury of over-educated layabouts
and we're acting like that's relief
we're playing games with language and
I'll tell you 200 billion that's chump
change problem is we're the Chumps right
that's why it doesn't matter it's so
easy to be generous and I think that if
you run into a quote young person and
they're going how dare you go let me ask
you this why would I be against it why
would I be be against that I should just
as easily say that money should be yours
and you should get relief but why would
I be against it because it's taking from
somebody else that's somebody else's
money right I actually think that this
is a good opportunity to teach people
where how redistribution works and how
this is actually theft and why it's
unconstitutional I would prefer if
somebody were to do this to go after the
banks and then absurd High interest
rates and the in the colleges who who
you know encourage people to take the
most absurd majors and take these loans
and I wonder I mean it's like if you're
if you're going to school right now
you've got to be thinking hell I ain't
paying off those loans because this is
going to happen again when they wipe
this slate clean it's only to build it
back up well right now borrowers with
debt that's unaffected by the
Forgiveness are Exempted from starting
to pay back their loans too so that's a
story for 33 months there's been a
moratorium on making student loan
payments across the board and there's
all also no interest accruing on the
loan so number one it's another handout
that's a bailout when you defer a loan
with no interest accruing on the loan it
is declining in real value because of
the inflation
Greg always talks about the declining
value of money well it helps these
borrowers but the burden that you're
talking about is not just the 150
billion plus because the interest isn't
accruing on these loans it is also this
is wildly idiotically inflationary at a
time that the Federal Reserve is hiking
interest rates to the Moon to fight the
inflation so what is happening people
who don't have there's a financial
burden somewhere if you go to buy a car
with a lease your rates going through
the roof because the fed's fighting
inflation because Joe Biden is still
handing out the money if your home is
going to collapse in value next year
because of the inflation and because of
the Federal Reserve is fighting it so
they're all these Financial burdens that
people will feel and bear because of
what Biden is doing with this plan it
helped them in the last election hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe live to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else